[Musique]
nous
mais
les poudres l'attendait dans une maison
de deux pièces
les témoins se regroupèrent dans l'une
d'elles je crie entraîna karima dans
l'autre et la pousse à sur la paillasse
garni d'un drap blanc qui faisait office
de lit l'épreuve qui commença pour ma
mère fut brutal humiliante
elle me l'a raconté des années plus tard
comme si elle avait lieu la veille les
témoins frappait à la porte en demandant
elle est déchirée ou pas
puis les poux sortie de la chambre en
brandissant le drame semble hanter les
vivats jaillir aussitôt karima gisait
sur la paillasse prostré sa famille
entra dans la chambre et la félicita de
ne pas l'avoir déshonoré le soir même
les pousse à la vivre chez les el
atrassi d'étudiantes
elle devint domestique vacant au soin du
père de la mère et du mari bien sûr ce
n'était là qu'un échantillon de la vie
qu'il a donnée
il y a deux ans amal el atrassi publier
son premier livre louvre musulmane né
dans le cher il ya 39 ans petite fille
alors elle vit à rosières près de
bourges
son enfance fut un quotidien de violence
familiale adolescente elle sera exilé
trois ans maroc avec ses deux soeurs à
la demande de son père
c'est alors la descente aux enfers violé
en réunion blessé à une jambe séquestré
humiliée elle reviendra en france
déguisée en garçon puis ce sera la
délinquance et la prison de page en page
nous raconte son cauchemar
les filles el atrassi sont soumises à la
loi de leur père alcoolique choukri
soumise à une religion quelle pratique
mais dont elle refuse les traditions
archaïques qui se réclament de l'islam
quand arriva le grand jour des en avance
mon père emmené à ma mère à l'hôpital de
bourges
il s'installa dans la salles d'attentes
pour fumer la barre au maroc la famille
l'attendait au ciel puis une infirmière
va lui annoncer
bravo monsieur c'est une belle petite
fille silence
ma mère avait commis une erreur une
faute même de surcroît le bébé était
prématurée elle m'a répété ce qui lui
avait dit en arrivant au pied du lié je
suis déçu franchement qui aurait quand
même pu me faire un garçon tu n'a pas
tenu ses promesses
j'imagine sans peine que le ton fut en
réalité plus grossier
un homme croit-il vraiment que la mère
décide du sexe de son enfant
comme mon premier frère aîné un an après
moi mon père a couru au bureau de poste
pour annoncer la nouvelle au pays
partait des drames farid fut le premier
de ses enfants qu'il est pris dans ses
bras il le couvrait de baisers le
faisait asseoir sur ses genoux pour
regarder la télé avec lui lui chantait
des chansons pendant nos vacances d'été
au pays
farid a été porté en triomphe dans la
tribu tandis que les youyous
retentissaient mes soeurs et moi
choukri nous l'aura assez répété étions
des inutilités entre deux voyages escale
à tours où elle vit désormais passage
par son incontournable café au coeur de
son ancien quartier du sanitas à
l'intérieur que des hommes presque comme
un défi son quotidien défendre la cause
des femmes musulmanes insoumise relation
est au pouvoir de son frère aussi le
très médiatique humoriste mustapha el
atrassi
j'ai un master 2
douala a l'air facile donc je pense
qu'on veut faire le rapprochement
quelques cette personne n'a pas apprécié
mais peut-être que je
je m'étonne autant et je vois ma vie
passée j'ai pas de
je parle des drones
car ces rations
un viol en réunion c'était chose qu'on
ne connaît pas dans ma culture
ça peut se sentir un peu tard tâche il a
mobilisé son réseau tout simple comme
tout simplement pour me faire bannir de
tous les médias télé où il connaît du
monde
on en connaît beaucoup j'ai passé une
partie de la famille jeune maman et lui
a dit de tourner moi mais mal d'atouts
et si je devais retourner dans le passé
j'aurais été satisfait de cette voiture
rouge tout à fait c'est très bien koné
sa fin de journée retour chez elle
aujourd'hui à mal à quatre enfants deux
filles deux garçons à les regarder vivre
on est loin bien loin de son passé si
loin du rejet de son père pour les
enfants nés de sexe féminin bonheur
familial retrouver c'est sa fierté sur
laquelle elle dresse tout en réserve
vraiment ce qui a vraiment mais vraiment
fait parce qu'il est ma vie c'est les
enfants c'est mon moteur
sans mes enfants je ne serais pas là
aujourd'hui donc je peux te dire assez
je peux dire que c'est mes enfants qui
m'ont fierté partagée par se fier ni qui
a vu le livre de sa mère de la
bibliothèque de son école on était
encore l'espagnol et la prochaine aux et
il fallait faire un travail sur la
discrimination
du coup on est tous allés au cdi et
avait plein plein plein plein plein de
livres posés sur une table sur la
discrimination est éveillé de ma mère
qui est déposé sur la table
moi je réagis écrit direct cette
rencontre
j'ai dit à tout le monde ses leaders au
début avait partiellement entendu
personne ne me croyait rêve d'aller
montrer qu'il est mon banc et c'est une
fierté pour toi boy mais heureusement
pourquoi parce que c'est logique non ben
si vous votre merci à se rallier
fièrement
[Rires]
[Musique]
depuis deux ans donc à mal rencontre des
médias d'europe du canada et du maghreb
et la presse française qui veut bien
entendre avec son passé comme seul
bagage avec ses blessures morales et
physiques
preuve aussi que sa peur s'est
transformé en combat même si la colère
ni siens et parfois menaçante
paris
retrouvailles avec l'aris mérigots
clarisse est aussi une femme rebelle
écrivain elle est le lien entre les
souvenirs et l'écriture
une écriture faite de mots simples lait
cru pendant un long moment elles se
parlent à ma les clarisses sont liés
l'un à l'autre par des parcours
difficiles des mois d'entretien des mois
douloureux pour dire pour confier ce kit
est parfois assez intime choukri se lève
de table et laisse tomber
maman est partie vers dieu un sourire
indéchiffrable se dessine sur ça fasse
mal rasé puis il répète votre mère est
partie vers dieu ensuite il se dirige
vers un placard en tire trois sauts
blanc de gros éponge et du savon liquide
allez les filles pour donne-t-il un saut
pour chacune comme ça pas de jaloux et
nous fait signe de le suivre jusqu'à la
voiture
incapable d'émettre un son nous le
regardons ouvrir les portières de la r18
le spectacle est effrayant on dirait une
scène de crime d' énorme tache de sang
se sont coagulé sur la banquette arrière
est en noir si on peut deviner que maman
s'est agité répand dans son sang soo
zèle des empreintes de main révèle les
endroits où elle s'est accrochée mais
tant de sang ce n'est pas possible sucre
il a tué
le cinquième jour après avoir entendu
les pneus de la r18 dans l'allée nous
sommes figés
nous avons aussi entendu la voix de
maman nous nous sommes regardés
puis nous nous sommes élancés pour
l'accueillir elle semblait reposer les
portait dans ses bras un petit corps
enveloppé dans une barboteuse jaune
[Musique]
la maison d'accueil
ça faisait longtemps
[Musique]
permet en entrant dans l'appartement
amal retrouve le canapé dans lequel les
rires se sont souvent mêlés aux larmes
[Musique]
bon ça te fait peur de retrouver ce
canapé sur lequel tu t'en es si j'ai
passé des traits et des mauvais quelques
mauvais mais nous avons aussi beaucoup
de pleurs vous pouvez ouvrir beaucoup
auraient des engueulades aussi normal
quoi
normal alors qu'il est toujours aussi
évasive je me mettais jamais été là tu
exiges vraies causes en avait marre avec
le lien avec tout est à faire à nouveau
réuni les deux jeunes femmes ont besoin
de parler de raconter comment ce livre
est né à son tour nous ne connaissons
pas les prime abord elle avait ne tire
pas on va dire du même du même monde et
elle m'a parlé de sa vie de sa vie
privée et ça m'a permet moi de me mettre
de me donner confiance
il ne mettra un peu plus à l'aise une
fois que j'ai eu en face de moi je
savais que ce serait difficile mais plus
elle a parlé
si vous voulez en fait il ya eu des
moments où je me disais vraiment on a
touché le fond dans le caractère sordide
dans la dans la tristesse absolue mais à
chaque fois je me disais ça y est là on
peut pas faire pire
je découvrais qu'il y avait un
souterrain supplémentaires et qu'on
pouvait les cendres encore plusieurs
étages plus bas
le moment qui a été vraiment dur c'est
le viol voilà le viol dont tu as mal a
été victime
et ça on l'a volontairement gardé pour
la fin
pourquoi parce que je savais que si elle
en parlait tout de suite et c'est ce
sera un moment extrêmement plombant et
que peut-être ça la bloquerait par la
suite et je préférais lui laisser le
temps de s'ouvrir peut-être pendant des
mois des valeurs qu'elle prend d'autres
choses et qu'on garde le plus dur pour
l'af
subitement les souvenirs l'envahissent
le silence est pesant
mais elle revient vite à s'en passer de
la culture culture arcade de mon père et
il se devait d'avoir pour premier enfant
un garçon après les plus les filles
pouvaient suivre ne posait pas de
problème mais le chef de famille devait
être un garçon mon appareil 3 fait la
troisième de la fratrie donc pour mon
père c'était c'était dur c'était trop
c'était une humiliation pour lui on
disait chez l'ours était mauvaise et
line ils avaient entre ils en avaient
ils avaient honte de ça ils disent à ma
mère tu n'es pas capable de me donner un
fils qui note que tu me chicaud défi
donc nous avons grandi moi en tout cas
j'ai grandi avec les lots avec il est
d'avoir été chiant donc on peut pas on
ne peut pas ne peut pas progresser on
peut pas évoluer avec cette idée là et
cette pensée là donc quand j'étais toute
petite fille je ne voulais pas être je
voulais devenir garçon et je me suis
masturbé je suis devenu masculine garçon
manqué et je me battais comme un garçon
j'ai joué comme un garçon je karaté aux
arbres comme un garçon il avait le
comportement d'un garçon
paris la nuit ce pari qui fait rêver les
serres el atrassi ce paris où le nom de
leurs frères ses cris parfois en grand
sur des affiches adolescente sa soeur
cadette l'entraînent dans une fugue
d'une fut pour quitter bourges à la
maison de rosières mais le voyage en
douce devient vite un cauchemar
arrivé seulement porte de vanves elles
sont arrêtées par la bac qui est placé
en garde à vue
c'est leur père choukri qui viendra les
récupérer
la punition sera violente et cette
échappée précipitera leur exil au maroc
vandeputte criait-il vous m'avez foutu
la honte dans tout le village
vous m'avez déshonoré hakima s'est mise
à genoux pour l'implorer elle qui avait
tenu tête aux policiers
cette audace lui valent une raclée
supplémentaires après l'avoir tiré par
les cheveux
choukri la secouer fouetter et criblé de
coups de pied puis il nous a ordonné de
nous cracher les uns sur les autres en
nous insultant
et on nous accusant mutuellement du
déshonneur des halles atrassi paris
parce que sa petite soeur voulait
devenir une artiste une danseuse motivé
par une chanson celle de madonna une
chanson où l'on dit papa papa don't
preach qui raconte l'histoire d'une
jeune fille qui demande à son père de ne
pas la juger
[Musique]
encore un voyage pour aller témoigner à
mal est toujours surprise de trouver son
livre empire sq
elle multiplie les interviews les
rencontres débats elle témoigne elle
raconte elle dénonce encore et encore
avec courage du voyage pour convaincre
de l'urgence
aujourd'hui n'est pas un jour comme les
autres nous sommes un 9 janvier en début
d'après midi trois heures avant c'était
le massacre à charlie hebdo à mal alors
a besoin de parler plus que jamais de la
nécessité de livrer sans crainte son
passé n'est pas seulement
dean ont cette culture archaïque par ce
patriarcat statut samedi d'être et on en
parle on en parlera toujours ça fait
partie de l'actualité
malheureusement et voilà ça dénonce usa
notre réaction par rapport à sa moue
santé gênés en ce moment l'équipe qui se
passe vraiment gêné bien évidemment je
suis gêné en tant qu'être humain je suis
gêné je ne cautionne évidemment pas tout
ce qui se passe mais si j'en ai
ras-le-bol qu'on est là ça sur le sou on
les appelle les coûts damas pour moi
c'est pas les faux d'amasser les fous de
dieu
ces défauts du diable mais les fous
d'allah non loin de là à la noue moi
j'ai appris la tolérance avec le coran
le respect le jeu ce que j'essaie
d'inculquer à mes enfants mais pas les
tuer des gens des innocents moyens pour
rien demandé donc je suis déçue mais
bien évidemment je possède pas tout ça
et on est bien le style faut bien lundi
que pour nous les premières victimes de
ces connards parce que ça rase des
connards des barbares des gens qui font
ce normal de charlie hebdo mais la syrie
et elle est victime de maux pourquoi il
ya tellement de choses qui se passent
donc de par le monde qu'il faut vraiment
les pointer du doigt en parler c'est 2
sans peur des menaces de sa communauté
religieuse elle est persuadée que les
femmes musulmanes ont un rôle urgent à
jouer et que l'éducation est l'une des
solutions et jacques les moments arrête
de mettre les garçons sur un piédestal
nous sommes même pour le niveau garçon
fille et je le vois encore
malheureusement que voilà le garçon
reste le roi
et ça ça aux mamans aussi de faire
chaude faire évoluer les mentalités déjà
dans un premier temps
essaie d'inculquer aux enfants à l'école
dès le départ que voilà
leur faire découvrir toutes les
religions pas que la religion musulmane
la bible la torah toutes les religions
leur parle et bien du mal qu'une
malheureusement donc toutes les
religions rien un petit peu voilà dans
toutes les religions la femme n'est pas
son n'est pas mis sur un piédestal faut
pas croire c'est pas que dans la langue
en abyme la femme et les doigts guazzini
à l'homme
[Musique]
pour eux les femmes font partie du décor
pareille aux fleurs qu'on arrache au
passage qu on hume et puis qu'on jette
pareille aux fruits que l'on mange à
moitié et dont on se débarrasse en
chemin
une femme hors de ses murs l'âme est
tombée est un objet qu'on peut souliers
en toute impunité parce que la tradition
le permet et parce que en prime on gagne
ainsi le respect des autres hommes
[Musique]
retour à rosières dans le cher pour
revoir la maison de leur enfance
un mâle est accompagné de sa petite
soeur à l'époque son père travailler à
la fabrique de gazinière
il rentrait tard souvent il ya des
scènes atroces des mamans qui
dégringolait de l'escalier qui siègent
le visage en sang la bouche en sang a
interdit quelques dents le papa qui
était la lumière au niveau qu'on puisse
pas aller à se courir nous conclut
guillaume on avait une façon cachée de
l'oignon partout parce que l'oignon
c'était je pensais que ça arrive que ça
réveille même que comac que ma mère
était vraiment morte et que ça va
ramener à la vie
donc on est passé de l'oignon sossou la
narine c'était un remède ancestrale de
souvenirs de nous qui nous amusions
aussi j'ai pas que de mauvais souvenirs
pour ça reste une belle maison un ghetto
et wes mignon des souvenirs de nombreux
abus c'est maman qui nous prend là qu'on
l'envoie déprimé en lavant adverse en
ménageant la voix fatiguée épuisée
résigné papa qui rendent à des heures
pas possibles
pas de noël bien évidemment on faisait
pas noël quelques années de recherche
catania bce qui offrait des kilos cedro
0 frais quelques tags des cadeaux tous
les noël on avait des noëls avec le
cieux mais personnellement c'était pas
noël on avait quelques anniversaires et
avait mes frères qui étaient gâtés et
nous en avait on récupère envahir les
west nile et restent malheureusement les
nouveaux locataires de la maison ne sont
pas là je voulais rentrer à la maison
moi je voulais voir tu voulais revoir
avoue la petite important pour rentrer
vraiment important hamad a déçu alors
elle se dirige chez un ancien voisin
michel bonjour ce avant la fin qu'au
théâtre on est bien rentré
michel a bien connu la famille à la
tracy avec les bons et les mauvais
épisode michel et sa femme avec abriter
quelque temps la mère d'amal épuisé par
la violence des coups de leur père à
l'occasion de ces retrouvailles les deux
soeurs reviennent sur la période de leur
exil au maroc car elle n'arrive toujours
pas à comprendre comment et pourquoi les
voisins ne se sont pas inquiétés de leur
disparition
durant trois ans mais en aucun cas on
avait pensé que c'était sans juger je
peux pas non plus ce projet c'était
quand même
michel avait acheté le livre d'amal
avant de partir elle lui dédicace
[Musique]
les filles el atrassi sont ainsi devenus
les domestiques sans peine des esclaves
nous sommes ce qu'est ce trait les
garçons à l'extérieur n'ont pas le droit
de nous regarder le courrier que nous
recevons occasionnellement les français
d'acheter avant de nous être remis les
colis d'anniversaire de ma mère sont
ouverts et fouillé et si des billets y
ont été glissés ils sont prélevés par
miloud ya sucre y envoie parfois un chef
mais il est impossible à encaisser car
il a fait des trous il nous est interdit
de nous servir du shampoing réservé aux
cousine en guise de savon nous n'avons
que les paillettes de tide les mêmes qui
servent à laver le sol une cousine sont
scolarisés mais nous n'y avons pas droit
nous sommes également moins bien nourri
et le gard à nous fûmes nous avisons
d'aller lui servir dans le réfrigérateur
l'exil au maroc est la période la plus
douloureuse de sa vie le viol en réunion
la blessure à la jambe droite que
personne ne soigne les humiliations
lieberman exilé dans cette famille où
leur père des caches elle et ses soeurs
comme pour les effacer d'un livret de
famille ammann n'a jamais compris
comment son père avait-il fait pour plus
personne ne les recherche
dernière entretient au café de la gare
en premier elle évoque un personnage qui
sera le comble de l'horreur pour elle
elle l'appelle le bouc
cette fois ci elle en parle à son coeur
quand on était en exil seul homme y
règne en tant que m ils avaient tous les
droits il s'octroyait tous les droits et
on lui octroyer tous les droits au
niveau c'était le seul homme et avec eux
des femmes
donc ça aurait dû être une cause de
fuite une coutume matriarcale avec des
femmes mais il règne en tant que m et je
revois une scène ou à regarder la tenais
simplement à soir et une de mes soeurs
lui nous dit parce qu'on se parle un
petit peu entre nous parce qu'on est
trois soeurs en exil et on a besoin
d'eux on était encore imprégné de
de 7,7 traces on est français donc on et
voilà on réagit c'est comme une fois
comme des françaises donc marquer
jackson passe à la télé et une soie de
l'une de mes soeurs une époque on se
retourne vers nous pour nous dire on a
comme jackson est beau il va asséner un
coup de poing au niveau de la danse adam
est tombé et s'est cassé en deux
donc ça te pousse ça pouvait être très
violent et montant ça pouvait aussi être
une violence morale
vous avez le sentiment que les sommes
dans votre culture mais dans d'autres
cultures aussi n'allait que les hommes
dans le cas présent
dans cette culture - cette religion
c'est parce qu'ils ont peur des femmes
dépensent je pensais pourquoi parce que
le texte qui compte qu'on est le premier
l'égal de l'homme tout simplement qu'on
peut accomplir plein de choses et que
derrière chaque homme chaque grand homme
se cache une femme tout simplement tout
simplement
en ahl vous êtes une femme on n'est pas
une féministe une femme tout simplement
pas tout court une femme qui est là qui
essayent de militer à montigné vos
contre tout que la justice reprochait
aux femmes dans tous les pays tous les
peuples et cultures toutes les classes
sociales
tout simplement et puis partent pas
monique montée - là j'essaye de faire
évoluer les choses nous rendent fiers
d'eux jaillissent travail ou les travail
sont durs aussi contre les hommes je
n'ai rien contre les hommes
j'ai des g2 et g2 j'ai deux garçons donc
je n'ai rien du tout contre les hommes
le pour la parité
tout à fait
hollande merci merci à vous je crie à
près de 70 ans partage son temps entre
le maroc et la france où il a conservé
sa petite maison de bourges près du
commissariat il s'est remarié et a eu
d'autres enfants que je ne connais pas
j'ignore même leur prénom sa nouvelle
samedi au maroc dans la villa qu'il a
fait construire avec les bénéfices de
ces trafics
j'ai appris qu'il n'y a chez lui aucune
photo aucun souvenir de ne même à
bourges le repentir qu'il m'a exprimé au
téléphone ne fut peut-être qu'épisodique
puisqu'il ne m'appelle qu'une fois par
an il ne veut sans doute pas trop se
rappeler le vaste au ratage que fut sa
vie de famille de mon côté je ne fais
pas d'effets en danger pour me rappeler
à son souvenir
je crie n'a plus de rapport avec
mustapha dont il ne peut ignorer qu'il a
rendue illustre le nom familiale je me
demande parfois comment un père peut
être si étranger à ses propres enfants
à la fin une immense pitié submerge tous
les autres sentiments qu'il m'a inspiré